egg prices have recently reached a
boiling point but most of us still love
to eat them at least in moderation even
if we fear they may raise our
cholesterol registered dietitian and
nutrition consultant Amy Goodson is here
to talk about the benefits of eggs in a
healthy diet and share some heart
healthy egg recipes good to see you Amy
thank you so much can you share the
current official guidance for eating
eggs yes so according to the American
Heart Association we can include eggs as
a part of a heart healthy diet for
healthy adult and that does include the
yolks so a lot of people don't realize
this but almost half of an egg's high
quality protein and most of its vitamins
and minerals especially those that are
essential for our brains and our bodies
are found in the Yoke and the U.S
dietary guidelines have not restricted
the cholesterol and the food that we eat
for many years and recommends as a part
of a healthy diet tell us about what
makes up a heart-healthy diet and our
eggs part of that we talk about a heart
healthy diet it's really focusing on the
big picture and including a variety of
nutrient-rich foods like fruits and
vegetables whole grains as well as lean
protein including eggs beans and legumes
nuts seafood and low-fat Dairy so when
we talk about heart healthy that also
means watching your salt intake as well
as limiting your saturated fat
consumption so we know that diets high
in saturated fat actually have the
biggest impact on a person's cholesterol
levels but the great news is that most
of the fat found in eggs is that
unsaturated good for you fat that
supports overall heart health is there a
perfect way to eat an egg and do you
have some favorite diet or favorite
favorite recipes excuse me with eggs
share some with us the best way to eat
AG is which ever way you like it so some
of my favorites are the recipes that
meet the American Heart association's
strict criteria for their heart track
certified recipes and you really can
find recipes for every meal of the day
so starting at breakfast I love these
veggie loaded egg muffins because you
can prep them in advance and have a
quick pop of protein ready to go during
the week put whatever veggies you have
in your eggs and then you literally cook
them like muffins in the oven for about
20 to 22 minutes easy ready to go pop of
protein great to meet you Amy thanks
again as soon as those egg prices come
down I think it'll be even more
attractive to us again appreciate you
have a great week and happy heart health
month
thank you happy heart health month to
you as well
all right thanks so much to Amy now you
can find more recipes lots of good
information about eggs on how to
incorporate them into your healthy diet
at
incredibleegg.com so good information
there and you know I think a lot of
people are kind of scared to eat eggs
too often because the fear of the higher
cholesterol and whatnot but I think if
you incorporate them in your diet and
you're not just constantly snacking on
eggs they can be a healthy addition to
what you're eating interesting about the
yolk too because you know a lot of
people go oh I just want to do the egg
whites only but right you're missing
something yeah the vitamins the protein
so good info Sherry moderation in
moderation I'd be nice